Things will happen to you…
… things that you cannot control.
A raw emotion will find you…
… when it does…
… what you do will define who you are.
Our heroes reunite.
Hey!
Oh my god.
Hi!
Are you okay?
Oh, yes!
I wanna do something that matters.
What the hell happened to my face!?
Welcome back.
I’m gonna compete with you, buddy!
Buddy?
They’re worried you can predict the future.
They’re worried people believe I can.
My name is Jon Stewart!
Welcome to The…
… Problem with Jon Stewart—we should put a comma in that.
The world wants to test us…
… to see if it can break us.
He didn’t beat you because he’s better…
… he beat you because he’s smarter.
Do you think we’ll make it?
Not without my team.
I think I can help you…
… but first thing I’m gonna do is completely unethical. I’m gonna give you a hug.
I’m a hugger.
Hey. Remember to focus on the here and now.
Living in the moment is a gift, that’s why they call it the present, y’all!